Ця жінка називає себе Веронікою і не хоче показувати своє обличчя.
Бо ще не готова відкрито розповідати про те,
що її колишній співмешканець, як вона стверджує,
розбещував її маленьку доньку.
Покидьок він. Майже два роки ми жили.
Вона розповідала, виходить, я була на роботі, а він був - точно не пам’ятаю -
три чи чотири місяці без роботи.
Він забирав її, відвозив, був весь час з нею вдома.
І ось, коли він забирав її зі школи,  так все і відбувалося.
Забирав її в кімнату, роздягав її, роздягався сам...
Вероніка з’ясувала це не одразу.
Якось після сварки співмешканець прийшов до неї
миритися з пропозицією жити далі разом.
Донька несподівано різко відповіла категоричною відмовою
і зважилася розповісти про все матері.
Сказати, що я була в шоці – це найпростіше формулювання.
По-перше, я відразу повірила своїй дитині.
Це 100 відсотків.
Але тут така ситуація, що, ось, віриш на сто відсотків,
але все одне важко повірити.
Потім я знайшла психолога - ми пішли,
і з’ясувалося, що дитина говорить правду.
Психолог сказав, що нам треба піти в поліцію.
Нині підозрюваний сидить в СІЗО, очікуючи рішення суду.
Цього Вероніка добилася, обійшовши усі можливі інстанції в Одесі,
написавши листи до усіх відповідальних чиновників в Києві, включно з президентом.
І в українських реаліях це вже частковий успіх.
Частіше підозрювані в таких злочинах проти дітей
уникають покарання, каже правозахисниця з Одеси Зоя Мельник.
Колишня поліцейська допомагає багатьом постраждалим від сексуального насильства.
Адже діти не одразу розповідають, а батьки здебільшого
не знають, що робити, і бояться розголосу.
Знаєте, коли легко доводиться до суду?
Коли є серйозні наслідки: зґвалтування з ушкодженнями, вбивство.
А коли це розбещення, то це дуже складно довести.
Це вчасно не виявляють, вчасно не проводять необхідні експертизи.
Все будується на свідченнях дитини, а правова система дитині не вірить.
Судово-правова система України взагалі "не дружня до дітей".
Такого висновку дійшла адвокатка Анна Круглякова,
яка  іноді захищає інтереси дітей в таких справах.
За спостереженнями адвокатки, нерідко комунікація правоохоронців з дітьми
перетворюється у справжнє знущання.
Якщо ми беремо дитину, наприклад, дівчинку, яка постраждала від сексуального насильства,
і їй на момент вчинення було 8 років.
А в нас колегія суддів - троє чоловіків.
Адвокати  обвинуваченого - чоловіки.
Обвинувачений - чоловік. Конвой.
Прокурор. Адвокат - я.
Секретар суду, і ось ця маленька дитина буде розповідати  про те, що з нею сталося?
Взагалі - ні. Навіть доросла жінка ніколи не розповість.
Україна ратифікувала низку конвенцій з прав дитини
Відповідно до європейської практики, дітей не можна допитувати.
Їх можна лише опитувати. І лише один раз.
І не слідчим чи-то суддею, які своїми, можливо, провокативними питаннями
можуть нанести психічну травму, а психологом у відповідному приміщенні,
яке має назву "зелена кімната" або "кімната дружня до дитини".
Судді, прокурори, адвокати
можуть бути присутні при цьому, але лише ось за таким дзеркалом.
- Як це було?
- Я уже спала,  мами вдома не було.
За деякий час відчула поруч із собою такі якісь
незрозумілі рухи
Він каже, що мами вдома немає і тебе ніхто не почує.
Я перехопила його руку
і вкусила за палець. І вибігла з квартири.
Ця історія - не справжня. Психологиня Маргарита Журавльова і її помічниця
демонструють, як таке опитування може відбуватися на практиці в "зеленій кімнаті",
де всі предмети продумані і слугують комфорту дитини:
зручні меблі, м’яка підлога, безшумні камери і головне - ці спеціальні ляльки.
Вони - інструмент спілкування на неприємні теми.
І якщо ми говоримо про дуже інтимні речі,
то дитина може навіть в присутності іншої людини, окрім психолога,
не розповідати про те, що сталося.
В нас є анатомічні ляльки, і дитина може продемонструвати,
навіть якщо не говорить про це.
В моїй практиці були випадки, коли дитина
все демонструвала, але нічого не говорила.
Ця "зелена кімната" була створена на базі Одеського державного університету
внутрішніх справ в рамках співпраці з судами.
Подібні кімнати є не в кожному місті, каже адвокатка Анна Круглякова.
Та навіть якщо є, добитися від суду проведення саме такого опитування не завжди можливо.
Судді посилаються на відсутність подібної норми в кримінальному кодексі,
а зі змістом європейської конвенції не завжди знайомі.
Іноді  я пишу великі такі клопотання про те,
коли і що ми ратифікували, таким чином,
навіть фотофіксацію "зеленої кімнати" додаю,
кажу, що ви повинні, бо інтереси дитини мають бути в пріоритеті.
Іноді досить важко, бо судді не розуміють, для чого це потрібно взагалі.
Зоя Мельник ще три роки тому працювала в патрульній поліції.
Вже тоді жінка досить  часто критикувала те,
як повільно просувалася правоохоронна реформа.
Серед іншого як поліцейська вона виїжджала на виклики
з приводу випадків домашнього насильства.
Побачене довго не відпускало жінку, особливо коли йшлося про дітей.
Тепер, ставши правозахисницею, Зоя Мельник відкрито заявляє про те,
що Україна як держава фактично знущається з дітей,
які постраждали від сексуального насильства.
Адже фахівці, які вміють з цим працювати, в правоохоронній системі майже відсутні.
Дорослий може принаймні дійти до райвідділу, звернутися,
написати заяву в поліцію, хоч якось відстояти свої права.
А дитина - ніби заручник ситуації.
Наприклад, якщо вдома насильство, дитина нічого не може зробити без допомоги ззовні.
Без якогось правозахисного руху взагалі важко чогось добитися.
Тому я вирішила цимзайматися.
Чим більше займаюся, тимбільше переконуюся, що це дуже потрібно.
Вероніка дізналася про існування "зеленої кімнати" вже після того,
як її доньку кілька разів вганяли в стрес,
допитуючи в райвідділах, у кабінетах слідчих.
Жінка вже тремтить в очікуванні судових засідань.
Обвинувальний вирок для неї - більше ніж мета.
Критерій у порятунку дитини - це те, що дитина дізнається,
що ця людина покарана.
Чому я цим займаюся?
Щоб вона розуміла, що це погано, щоб інший дядько, якщо підійде
і буде - не дай, Боже - щось схоже робити,
то щоб вона розуміла, що це погано.
Одеська правозахисниця Зоя Мельник майже щодня отримує повідомлення
від дітей і їхніх батьків про різні види насильства.
Чекати, поки Верховна Рада внесе зміни до Кримінального кодексу
і щодо "зеленої кімнати", і щодо права дитини на того ж адвоката, експоліцейська не хоче.
Адже з кожним днем очікування жертв лише більшає.
Тож тим часом разом з колегами вона розробляє рекомендації, як діяти,
шукає жертвам адвокатів і психологів-волонтерів.
Амбітна мета правозахисниці -
створення всеукраїнської мережі правової і психологічної допомоги дітям.